social media was supposed to be the less
domain certainly in the early days it
seemed like it would be an unstoppable
force to connect the young and take the
movement to victory at the polls if you
decided in elections by likes and
retweets well we'd already be three
years into a socialist dystopia but
culturally social media has fermented a
runaway form of aggressive liberalism
synonymous with the left debates on
gender masculinity and race progresses
such a pace that the general public have
no chance of keeping up and it is
different I think to 90s political
correctness because those debates
particularly around gender and
acceptance of homosexuality were held in
an era of fewer channels and media
outlets therefore the progress was
understood by all and longer-lasting now
discourse involves at a frantic pace
leaving left-of-center parties adopting
or echoing stances which the vast
majority of people are barely aware of
jos Winston's policy on a third gender
on passports and Corbin introducing
himself for his preferred pronouns left
many ordinary people scratching their
heads it's time that the left realized
social media is an unreliable friend I
kind of reject the idea that there are
people who are interested in women's
rights and trans rights and then there's
ordinary people for example there are
trans people all over the country in all
kinds of communities and I think they
would regard anything that helps
recognize their rights to be treated
equally as something Universal not just
for a liberal metropolitan elite and
what I take from what you're saying is
the fact that age is a huge divide it's
actually the most powerful divide in
politics now it's not a phrase like sis
for example which in are kind of like
lovey dovey metropolitan world we're
aware of if you ask them the vast
majority of Britain what that means to
introduce yourself as a space male I
think that would there'll be a lot of
younger people that wouldn't know what
and in case there's anyone watching this
who doesn't know what it means this male
is someone who awful you can ask me yes
yes and identifies I'm and identify you
as that I think that yeah I know you
know I get email from people saying my
pronouns are
at the end of their Eve do you have that
on your email signature I know I'm lying
on my Twitter I do yeah I swear they've
got people around the country are
watching this right now I don't but some
people sign off their email saying you
know you know address my pronouns are
she and her just so that you know oh I
get it how I self-identifying I first
time we saw that which wasn't that long
ago I didn't have a problem with it I
just learnt that that's something that
people are doing I mean I think what I
take from what you're saying is that a
lot of people feel left out of this
conversation
yeah and that they're not included in it
and that they're not necessarily on
board with it and I think I agree in the
sense that when you look at for example
new labor one of the big problems of new
labor for me say it's multiculturalism
agenda was that it was I agree obviously
with the sentiments of celebrating the
fact that we're a multicultural society
but multiculturalism and a new labor was
something I think in hindsight that was
imposed from the top down it wasn't
something that came up from a
groundswell of grassroots feeling and
you need it you need consensus if you
want to build social change and you want
to build a society that's inclusive you
need to bring people on board but the
questions how do you do not to reject
the fact that some people I just say I'm
saying that it's different now and it's
able to advance a pace that most people
can't keep up with and the problem for
the left is that way of thinking is now
synonymous with the left politically so
it's almost like whoa Kees con like the
sort of militant wing of momentum but
can I just say I totally disagree that
social media is the domain of the left
you know often people say both sides and
I think this is actually an example
where it really is because in the last
few years the right has used social
media much more effectively than the
left if you look at Donald Trump do many
Soviets or adverts I mean actually in
terms of engaging with people that think
the way that they do and then being able
to actually have that materialized into
winning elections if you look at Donald
Trump he is whether you agree with him
or not he is prolific on social media we
talk about if you look at even with
David Cameron's election part of the
reason Cameron won or did better than
was expected was because of the way
they effectively use social media you
know you had a message that chimed with
more people use those new technologies
to engage people you mentioned stats on
social media I mean you look at the
Facebook Likes in November of 2019 joe
Swinson 14,000 I mean that I think I'm
almost touching that number Boris
Johnson nearly 750,000 nigel farage just
over 900,000 jeremy corbyn nearly one
and a half million I mean if you did it
as a Facebook poll we'd already all have
free broadband but it's a lot more
complicated there's kind of stats with a
pinch of salt because you know it's
really easy to access what people will
call click farms where you can actually
artificially generate likes and
interaction and traffic etc but to me I
don't regard social media as the domain
of the left 67% of people in the UK 67%
of the UK population are active social
media users so that is prolific but what
I think is I regard social media as a
tool I think in lots of instances
particularly in the 2017 election the
left was more organized in in leveraging
that tool they had a better strategy
around it I think when it comes to
Donald Trump I think what he's done is
use this new media to capitalize on
people's distrust of traditional media
so for example he will say fake news
they're doing this and actually when it
came to this election I found what the
print media did is really quite
overstepping their mark so you saw many
print well you saw many print
publications one in particular springs
to my mind publishing the email
addresses of political candidates to try
and leverage their audience to pressure
them to stand down what's it got to do
with a print media who can stand an
election it's none of their business
quite I think the thing just to cope I'm
not saying that as social media is an
absolute preserve of the left arm
presents a unique problem for the list
because it's being sort of bound up with
some of the the more woke elements of
liberal thinking and the public is sort
of thinking if I if I vote labor or
these the kind of concerns that will be
seen as priorities when actually they're
gonna get a grip on it what will happen
well they let it yeah well I mean I
think it's what has happened is is
what's already happened I think we're
now in the aftermath of that I mean you
look at like canvases and focus groups
throughout the election that we're
coming back
and saying in all those labor marginals
that voted leave that this is this is a
problem and yeah because the the sort of
tenor of online debate was probably more
remain led they moved to a position
position that was ultimately destructive
for them so I think it's already
happened and it's whether or not they
continue to listen to themselves or the
message that the electorate are sending
I mean you're definitely right that how
people respond on social media does not
reflect how people vote in the elections
if you look at labor in the
Conservatives jeremy corbyn's facebook
video it's got eighty six point two
million views and Boris Johnson's got
only twenty four point five million so
you know if you were to try and predict
the outcome on that you would be so off
mark but this comes back to my point
about age that a half of people under
twenty four voted labour and only
fourteen percent of people over seventy
voted lit voted labour so the people who
use social media are more likely to
respond to the left but they don't vote
they don't very hate to be even though
all young people registered to vote
didn't see the games because they're too
young or they just can't be bothered I
mean that's such a caricature I think
there are a number of reasons what this
election unhelpfully was also timed with
holidays from universities and people
move around a lot it's and they're not
they don't necessarily have a habit of
voting they need to be they need to vote
election I do I struggle to vote a lot
of us felt very politically homeless in
this election and I think a lot of
people in the country feel very
disenfranchised by the way our party
politics it's representing us at the
moment and I think I'm already in the
habit was my first time what would I
have done I slightly take issue learn
young people off the hook because the
thing is you know people won't make a
difference politics will never be sexier
or more vital than it is now i mean ii
might people make the analogies with
sort of a netflix type mini-series and
it's true it has been compelling viewing
so my question to young people is if
you're not going to find now when do you
it's never been more importantly one
Latics doesn't have to come to you
you've got to come to where I think
social media is failing is with
accountability so at the moment
random can set up an account with any
old person English any old any old
content you should have get rid of an
anonymized accountants make sure that
there's accountability for what people
are saying and that would stop some of
the problems that we're discussing only
the debut boy Jeff could have linked
Jeremy Corbyn politics and sexy it's not
after you hear those three put together
it's time to press pause on that debate
now after when you've done the ironing
you need to Don my socks honey and I'll
have a scotch and Soda and can you get
the hostess trolley because I'm hungry
Deary coming up next on the pledge happy
wives happy live
[Music]